wie ordnet du bist ein chaos naja ich
bin dankbar dass es mal so gesagt man
ist und wiederholt auch noch mal gern
wir blicken auf afghanistan und wir
stellen fest die terroristen haben
gewonnen der westen hat verloren wir
stellen fest dass wertesystem das wir
verändern wollten haben wir nicht
verändert wir stellen fest der weg der
modernen menschen in afghanistan die
anders leben wollen die studieren wollen
die sich bilden wollen insbesondere
frauen sind zurückgestoßen eine art
vorzeit steinzeit weil wir nicht in der
lage waren das zu verändern da stellen
sich ja ganz entscheidende fragen in der
zukunft für die zukunft nämlich können
wir eigentlich jemals wieder im namen
der humanität dem namen der
menschenrechte im namen der
gerechtigkeit im namen der demokratie in
anderen ländern sein um dort zu helfen
wo man auf marli die momentaufnahme sagt
wir halten uns raus weil es sonst zu
enden kann wie in afghanistan
ich finde das ein extrem
unbefriedigendes zwischenergebnis weil
wenn man das weiterdenkt wird daraus ja
jeder kümmert sich nur um seinen eigenen
kram und wenn man das weiterdenkt sind
wir zurück in einer welt rivalisierender
kulturen staaten
militärmächte also sozusagen von
afghanistan geht das signal aus 50 jahre
rückwärts statt 50 jahren nach vorne wie
wir eigentlich denken sollen
[Musik]